we have a chance to watch justin dunn in
his second start of the season only his
sixth career major league start of
course the september call-up last year
be interesting to see what the effects
are facing the same team for the second
straight start mike trout obviously all
the stress of having the baby and doing
that now back to doing what he does best
play baseball yeah he's going to fair
here tonight nola setting up outside
it's a breaking ball hammered out toward
left center field hit well kyle lewis
back that's gone
big fly for mike trout welcome back
how's the song go one nothing halos
and the first inning homerun power
continues for trout
that's probably for beckham i'm sure
that was homer's in his first at-bat
first day back
407 feet for trout papa trout going yard
and everyone's just thinking really he
homered and his first at-bat is after
becoming a father just got up to seattle
last night unbelievable jon snowboarding
on it's brian goodwood
two out free pass albert gets an
opportunity here has had four hits so
far half of them have been home runs
next one on albert and he swings and
drives the ball deep down the left side
and that one is out of here
albert pujols connects down by the
angels bullpen area and boy oh boy the
angels are swinging the bats here in the
first inning a pair of home runs crowd
and poo holes albert shot a two-run shot
and it's three-nothing halos joe adele
making his major league debut tonight
will come up for his first big league
played appearance middle of the infield
one two again there's a little dribbler
left side here comes kyle seeger
transfer over to first out of time first
big league hit for joe adele it's an
infield knock welcome to the show joe
adele first at bat base hit
didn't trout get his first major league
head in infield head as well i believe
he may have yeah i i think that that was
the case
yes we need that baseball
looking for his first win of the season
this is his third start he was the
angel's opening day starter this season
left field is andrew heaney he's all
about
and goodbye thus far no wins no losses
nine and two third innings seven hits 12
strikeouts just one walk on the year
yeah he's throwing the ball exceptional
his fastball and the command of his
fastball has been great 90-94 will throw
a slider and change up the last start up
4-1
and the dreaded no decision as lopes
lines with albert they doubled up
crawford
albert's still quick at first
lokes hit that ball right on the money
there of angel base runners one out
anthony struck out his first time up
slicing drive
coming over is dylan moore he's got the
wheels to get it
and the runner at second
he thought that that ball was going to
get down rendezvous and he's doubled up
the windup and the 2-2 to seeger swung
on line drive center field and that's
going to drop in front of trout for a
base hit so kyle seeger with a leadoff
single
here in the bottom half of any number
two three nothing angels here's catcher
austin nola
back up the middle and rendezvous gloves
it flips it to fletcher for one relay
back to first not in time wow howard off
the base i think albert was shocked that
red hevo got to that baseball as well
what a play that was the americans have
runners down the corner and brings up
kyle lewis two and two of the count next
delivery and that one is ripped down the
left side out on the warning track the
rim of the track though gathering it in
is good when that ball got out there in
a hurry
about a third of the order joe adele
jason castro luis ran heap
he went around
hola has to throw down the first fleet
to strikeout one away
[Applause]
the wind-up and the one-two pitch and a
swing and a miss and a change-up for
strike three so back-to-back strikeouts
for done here in the top of the fourth
inning al seeger two-hour walk seeger
aboard for the second time first pitch
to austin nola he swings and lines this
out to left field good one tracking it
into the gap he dives and he can't make
the catch it rolls to the base of the
wall seeger is past second he's motoring
into the third and makes a turn he's
coming home to score nola chugging for
three headlong slide well ahead of the
throw
it's an rbi triple for austin nola
and the mariners are on the board
three to one in the bottom of the sixth
the last 14 angel batters retired in a
row after angels got off to the quick
start castro will step up
cranked
deep center field straight away lewis at
the wall he makes the catch
kyle lewis another moment for him and he
makes the catch he just brought it back
kyle lewis with some robbery in center
field climbing the ladder above the
yellow stripe it's out number two and he
saves a run that's a pretty good
combination at the plate and then at
first base with good speed to put
something on potentially here to try to
get the offense rolling david fletcher
the batter at the top of the seventh
that is hammered out to deep left field
toward the corner that one is gone
fletch has done it his first of the
season gooby a big fly fletch lives
again five to one angels
dylan moore double
and a fly to center one for two
down the line
and
go on a home run
dylan moore
makes it a 5-2 ball game his second
homer in the season rbi number four
dylan moore's had a nice game going two
for three a double in a home run
chopper left side fletcher to the
backhand off balance throw to albertgato
seriously fletch
wow what a play
david fletcher gets into the hole just
backhands us and
talk about it so much with david
fletcher how quickly he's able to take
it from the glove and get rid of it
first pitch swinging lofts went out to
brian goodwin in left field he's
underneath it
light that baby up as the angels pick up
the open of the series against seattle
the final once again 5-3 halo